Speaker 1: Donald Trump has absolutely lost
it on his new blog over the news that a grand
jury has been convened in Manhattan to evaluate
evidence that Donald Trump and or his associates
and or his organization have committed crimes.
As a reminder, we already outlined that The
Washington Post reports a grand jury panel
has been convened and it will sit three days
a week for six months.
They will be looking at all sorts of different
possible crimes that Trump Associates and
his organization may have committed.
Donald Trump reacting immediately triggered,
which is exactly what we've predicted for
a long time, which is if these criminal probes
get going once Trump is out of office, Trump
is going to lose his mind and he's already
losing his mind.
And nothing has even happened yet.
Let's review his blog post where Donald Trump
opens by saying this is a continuation of
the greatest witch hunt in American history.
It began the day I came down the escalator
in Trump Tower and it's never stopped.
They wasted two years and forty eight million
in taxpayer dollars on Mueller and Russia,
Russia, Russia.
Now, remember, the Mueller probe recovered
more money than it cost.
Trump goes on to say impeachment Hoke's No.
One, impeachment hoax number two.
And it continues to this day with illegally
leaked confidential information.
No other president in history has had to put
up with.
What I have had to add on top of all that,
I have done a great job for our country, whether
it's taxes, regulations or military veteran
space force, our border, speedy creation of
a great vaccine set to be a miracle and protecting
the Second Amendment.
We could do an hour debunking each of those.
This is purely political and an affront to
the almost 75 million voters who supported
me in the presidential election.
And it's being driven by a heart by highly
partizan Democrat prosecutors.
New York City and state are suffering the
highest crime rates in history.
That's not true.
And instead of going after murderers, drug
dealers, human traffickers and others, they
come after Donald Trump.
Interesting that today a poll came out indicating
I'm far in the lead for the Republican presidential
primary and the general election in twenty
twenty four.
That's not true.
Not that second part.
And lastly, Trump says our country is broken,
our elections are rigged, corrupt and stolen.
Not true.
Our prosecutors are politicized.
That I will just have to keep on fighting
like I have been for the last five years.
Trump off the rails and just imagine if there
are charges.
Just imagine if there are charges.
What will happen with this man's psyche.
Donald Trump Jr. getting in on the action,
retweeting someone named Mike Davis, who said,
quote, Since 1923, the Trump family has built
a worldwide real estate and hospitality empire.
Now highly partizan Democrat prosecutors are
on a witch hunt to find paperwork, crimes,
crimes in quotes, and they ignore clear evidence
of foreign corruption and other real crimes
by the Biden crime family.
Folks, it is conspiracies all the way down.
You know the phrase, it's turtles all the
way down.
It is conspiracies just all the way down.
And this is going to be a very interesting
six months.
The timeline that is mentioned would be.
And if there will be indictments around the
end of summer and then starting to get into
court and seeing what direction these indictments
will go in the fall, so between now and November,
potentially just a series of never ending
insanity is what we are expecting to see here.
We have on Monday, Memorial Day, an incredible
one day David Pakman show membership special.
We have had a lot of membership attrition
due to the continued financial strain that
many people are under.
That sad and I understand that hundreds of
members canceling over the last couple of
months.
We are trying to do something to turn that
around.
And that is that Monday, Memorial Day, we're
doing a single day membership special.
I would love for you to participate.
Just get on my newsletter at David Pakman
dot com, and then Monday morning you'll hear
all about it.
All right, quick break.
Let me know on Twitter, what do you expect
to come of this grand jury?
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Let us not forget that you can at any time
of day, if at three fifty in
the morning you get a hankering for a David
Pakma